dos de los puntos que definen un
cuadrilátero son menos cuatro menos 2 y
05 el cuadrilátero permanece invariable
bajo una reflexión con respecto a la
recta e iguala x medios y una reflexión
con respecto a la recta igual a menos 2
x más 5 dibuja y clasifica el
cuadrilátero muy bien vamos a poner
estos dos puntos aquí en los ejes
ordenados uno de ellos es el menos 4 - 2
- 4 - 2 este punto de acá voy a marcarlo
en color azul y el otro es el 0 50
puntos 1 2 3 4 5 sería este punto que
estoy pintando en rosa que está sobre el
eje que va y nos dicen que el
cuadrilátero permanece en variante bajo
reflexiones con respecto a algunas
rectas así que déjame dibujar estas dos
rectas para ver con respecto a qué vamos
a reflejar bueno pues voy a empezar
dibujando esta de acá se iguala x
como no tiene nada ha sumado eso quiere
decir que pasa por el origen si x es 0 y
es igual a 0 entonces uno de los puntos
de la recta sería este de acá y además
la pendiente es un medio cada que
avanzamos una unidad subimos una unidad
un avance de uno en x es medio avance o
bien también podemos decirlo como que
cada vez que avanzamos 12 x subimos uno
en que entonces este punto también
estaría este punto también en este punto
también y este punto también y hacia el
otro lado
pues aquí tendríamos que regresar dos y
bajar uno este de acá este punto azul
que ya teníamos también está este de acá
y así sucesivamente déjame dibujarla la
línea utilizando la herramienta de línea
recta nos quedaría algo de este estilo
algo de este estilo muy bien esta de acá
es la recta que es igual a equis
es igual a x medios muy bien y ahora voy
a dibujar la otra recta la recta igual a
menos 2 x 5 corta al eje y en 5 porque
aquí tenemos que estamos sumando 5 si x
es igual a 0 que es igual a 5 entonces
pasaría por este punto que ya tenemos la
voy a pintar en color naranja y su
pendiente es menos 2 es decir cada vez
que avanzamos 1 en x se baja 2 deng
pasaría por este punto de acá por este
punto de acá por este punto de acá este
de acá estoy acá y hacia el otro lado si
regresamos 1 entonces aumenta en 2 si x
va a uno a la izquierda lleva 1 hacia
arriba pasaría por acá y por acá la voy
a pintar con la herramienta de de línea
recta nos quedaría más o menos así muy
bien entonces esa de ahí es la recta que
es igual a menos 2 x menos 2x
+ 5 ya que tenemos esas rectas podemos
reflejar los vértices verdad nos están
diciendo que el cuadrilátero permanece
invariable bajo bajo ciertas reflexiones
entonces los otros vértices de este
cuadrilátero los podemos obtener
reflejando estos vértices en las rectas
correspondientes bueno déjame empezar
reflejando con respecto a la recta verde
si reflejamos este punto con respecto a
la recta verde no pasa nada caemos
ahí mismo es como si el punto estuviera
no se estuviera sobre el espejo entonces
no le pasa nada pero qué sucede si
reflejamos este punto de acá bueno pues
para reflejar tendríamos que bajar
perpendicularmente a esta recta y luego
recorrer un tramo igual y una cosa bien
importante es que estas dos rectas son
perpendiculares son perpendiculares aquí
tenemos un ángulo de 90 grados porque
sabemos esto por la relación que tienen
entre sus pendientes si tenemos que una
recta tiene pendiente m entonces
cualquier otra recta que sea
perpendicular a ésta tiene como
pendiente l
es un negativo es decir tiene como
pendiente menos 1 / m
sale entonces por ejemplo si la primera
recta tiene pendiente igual a un medio
cuál es el inverso negativo de un medio
el inverso es 2 y el negativo es menos 2
y por lo tanto tenemos que esta segunda
recta que tiene pendiente menos 2 es
perpendicular bueno eso va a ser muy
útil porque entonces para reflejar
simplemente tenemos que avanzar sobre la
recta naranja para reflejar con respecto
a la recta verde y cuando estamos
avanzando bueno pues vamos uno a la
derecha dos para abajo uno a la derecha
dos para abajo y llegamos a la recta
verde entonces hay que recorrer eso
mismo uno a la derecha dos para abajo
uno a la derecha dos para abajo y
llegamos a este punto de acá que voy a
pintar en color morado este punto de acá
entonces este punto de la reflexión de
este punto de acá con respecto a la
recta verde y por lo tanto es otro de
los vértices del cuadrilátero y si ahora
reflejamos este punto con respecto a la
recta naranja a dónde llegamos
bueno pues avanzamos dos a la derecha
uno arriba dos a la derecha uno arriba
dos a la derecha uno arriba es decir
avanzamos tres veces así también hay que
avanzar tres veces así hacia el otro
lado uno dos tres
llegamos a este punto de acá que voy a
poner con este color con un morado un
poco más claro y listo con esto
conseguimos los vértices de nuestro
cuadrilátero vamos a dibujar el
cuadrilátero déjame empezar dibujando
este segmento de acá este segmento que
en estos dos puntos y este segmento de
acá notemos que esos dos segmentos son
paralelos para ver que son paralelos
podemos ver que tienen la misma
pendiente y cuál es la pendiente
bueno pues observa si avanzamos 1-2-3-4
en x entonces avanzamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 en
ya entonces tenemos que la pendiente es
7 7 cuartos
la diferencia entre la diferencia en x y
de este lado también avanzamos 1234 en x
y 1234567 en g de modo que la pendiente
también es siete cuartos y por lo tanto
estos dos segmentos son paralelos lo voy
a indicar con estas flechas como siempre
y vamos a ver qué sucede con los otros
dos lados este segmento de acá este
segmento de acá es paralelo también a
este segmento de acá son los otros dos
lados que nos faltaban cómo le hacemos
para ver que son paralelos misma idea
calculamos la pendiente acá
avanzamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 en x y bajamos
1 en g
entonces la pendiente es menos 1 que
bajamos en dividido entre 8 que
aumentamos en x y de manera similar se
puede ver que la pendiente de acá
también es menos un octavo y por lo
tanto estos dos segmentos también son
paralelos
y eso es lo que nos dice es que este
cuadrilátero al menos es un
paralelogramo pero yo digo que además
los cuatro lados son iguales podríamos
usar la fórmula de distancia pero sería
algo complicado mejor tomemos esta
diagonal y esta diagonal de acá y
observemos que todos estos ángulos son
de 90 90 grados 90 90 grados y por lo
tanto que tenemos aquí tenemos un
paralelogramo en el cual las diagonales
son perpendiculares y por lo tanto este
paralelogramo con diagonales que se
intersectan en 90 grados es rombo